Das ist das Brandenburger Tor.
Aber dieses steht nicht in Berlin,
sondern in Potsdam,
Hauptstadt des Bundeslandes Brandenburg.
Hier geht es beschaulich zu.
Im Advent ist die Stadt besonders
herausgeputzt.
In Potsdam haben zahlreiche preußische
Herrscher ihre Spuren hinterlassen.
Preußen war einer der wichtigsten
europäischen Staaten
vom 18. Jahrhundert bis 1918.
Das alte Stadtschloss aus jener Zeit wurde
wieder aufgebaut -
ebenso wie der Palast Barberini.
Potsdam pflegt sein Erbe.
Den Einfluss der verschiedenen Könige
in Potsdam kann man natürlich bis heute
am Stadtbild nachvollziehen.
Es war immer Residenzstadt bis 1918,
das heißt also, diese Stadt sollte eine schöne
sein.
Im Prinzip ist das Erscheinungsbild der Stadt
durch ihre Vergangenheit eine [s],
die sehr heimisch wirkt auf viele.
Und das möchten viele bewahren und wieder
errichten.
Das Holländische Viertel mitten in Potsdam.
Es geht auf Friedrich Wilhelm den Ersten
zurück,
den sogenannten preußischen
Soldatenkönig.
Er war ein großer Anhänger der Niederlande,
und weil er vom Wissen des Landes
profitieren wollte,
lud er Handwerker und Baumeister nach
Potsdam ein.
So entstand das größte zusammenhängende
Bauensemble
im holländischen Stil in Deutschland.
Ich selber bin in der Nähe der holländischen
Grenze geboren und ich dachte immer:
Was ist hier denn so besonders?
Aber der Soldatenkönig hat auch immer noch
bei mir, 250 Jahre später,
ein Gefühl erreicht, was er damals schon
schaffen wollte, nämlich,
dass man sich hier heimisch fühlt.
Bis heute wird hier zu Weihnachten
eine niederländische Tradition gefeiert:
An einem Adventswochenende kommt
Sinterklaas in das Viertel.
Dann zeigen niederländische Handwerker
ihr Angebot,
und die holländische Version des Nikolaus'
zieht durch die Straßen.
Nicht niederländisch, aber auch eine
Institution der Stadt: die Confiserie Felicitas.
In der Adventszeit herrscht hier Hochbetrieb.
Die Konditoren backen Potsdam-typisches
Gebäck und kreieren Pralinen.
Besonders beliebt ist eine Büste
aus Schokolade.
Sie zeigt die berühmte Preußenkönigin Luise.
Die Figuren sind natürlich mit der Geschichte
von Potsdam eng verbunden.
Dadurch, dass Luise wirklich ‘ne sehr,
sehr positive Figur ist,
wird sie auch noch sehr gerne gekauft,
verschenkt.
Heute ist Potsdam eine moderne Stadt.
Aber das alte Preußen lebt überall
ein bisschen weiter.
Sogar auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt.
Dort können Besucher Laternen und Lametta
in einer ganz bestimmten Farbe bewundern.
Blau, preußisch Blau wird meistens
mit den Uniformen als Allererstes assoziiert,
der preußischen Armee,
denn unter dem Soldatenkönig wurden
die Farben
der vorher vielen Uniformenfarben
vereinheitlicht,
nämlich zu preußisch Blau.
Und Potsdams blauer Lichterglanz ist
eigentlich der einzige Weihnachtsmarkt
in Deutschland, der mit Blau arbeitet.
Ein blauer Lichterglanz: Einst war das
als Marketingcoup der Stadt gedacht.
Inzwischen ist es zur Tradition geworden.
Budenbesitzer greifen das Blau
bei ihren Ständen auf.
Und sogar die Schlittschuhbahn
am Luisenplatz ist bläulich eingefärbt.
Aber was denken die Besucher darüber?
Der bläuliche Glanz, also ich finde ihn
ästhetisch sehr schön.
Er hat irgendwie sowas sehr Weiches.
Mir gefällt es ganz gut.
Es gibt ganz viele Sterne.
Und blau ist letztens meine Lieblingsfarbe.
Letztens.
Ist mal was ganz anderes.
Zu Hause würde ich‘s nicht machen.
Ne, ich auch nicht.
Aber hier sieht’s vielleicht nicht schlecht aus.
Na, ich mag’s eher klassisch.
Ich find die blauen Lichter immer sehr schön.
Also, es gibt dem Ganzen immer noch so ‘ne
besondere Atmosphäre,
neben den weißen Lichtern,
die immer an den Häusern dran sind.
Der Weihnachtsmarkt zeigt Potsdam,
wie es heute ist:
Das blaue Licht wirkt modern
und erinnert an die lange Tradition der Stadt.